hello everyone and welcome to the final
game of day two of the world rabbit
championship it's the clash of leaders
Magnus Carlsen versus Lacroix alien
vietnamese grandmaster both of them on
seven points so our van cow and maxime
beaugeois grove
however maxime beaugeois grabbing the
van cow drew their game very early van
how I drew all of his games very early
after his draw against Magnus he just
kept drawing a quick draw against
momager quick dragons dominguez quick
dragons the maxime beaugeois graph so
he's most likely saving his energy for
tomorrow while still keeping a nice a
nice core I mean draws against those
players is a perfectly acceptable result
so now both caution and look long lean
have a chance to take over the lead in
the tournament which is pretty pretty
nice so Magnus with the white pieces
opens with d4 we have d5 and c4 and like
the title suggests we have d captors and
c4 the Queens gambit accepted is on the
board something not seen very often in
top-tier tournaments with E for Knight
to f6 and now he v with Knight to d5 and
now Magnus recaptures the point Bishop
captures on c4 Knight the b6 pushing the
bishop back and Bishop to b3 which is a
which is very nice since your bishop is
already on a very nice diagonal we have
Bishop to f5 first developing light
square bishop before closing the center
we have Knight to f3 and only now II 6
Magnus goes for Knight to c3 continues
development and Knight to c6 now with
Bishop to e3
developing adding more protection to the
d4 pawn and now Bishop to e7 now
preparing to castle
Magnus castles Anglian castles and here
there's a game dinkler and played
against Ventura Hari Krishna where h3
was played in this year's Tata Steel
blitz edition and hari creation was able
to beat it in that game but here we have
a three by Carlsen we have Knights to a5
pushing the bishop back and now a bishop
to c2 now offering a trade of bishops
and here best for black is to just
capture the bishop which is something
that's very usually done by black one
black develops his bishop on this
diagonal white
country with this light square bishop
and then most most more often than not
you will see this trade of the light
square bishop but here we have Queen to
d7 allowing Magnus to gain control of
the center completely we have Bishop
Tadros on f5 by Magnus he captures on f5
and now d5 creating this massive center
here and he controls a lot of very
important squares in blacks camp we at
night the c-4 attacking the bishop and
the b2 pawn here Magnus straights we
have night back characters and b6 and
now Queen to b3 now connecting rooks
preparing rook 881 and rook F to e 1 the
gain complete control of the center of
the board and there is the old saying he
who controls the center will win the
game so let's see if this holds
we have rook a to d8 by Liam and rook a
to d1 by Magnus rook F to e 8 and now
rook F to e 1 and now if you look at
this it's just not something you see
very often in in top tier play now we
have g6 and now you will be able to ship
the bishop maybe to g7 to help out with
with the center here and give the rooks
some some files to work on but H for
Magnus precursor is h5 he wants to start
also an attack on the King side we have
came to g7 and h5 we have Bishop to c5
freeing the bishop this way as the King
now occupies the g7 square and now Queen
to c2 moving the Queen preparing before
we have a 5 stopping before and now
Queen to c1 with ideas of shifting the
Queen over to the Kings side we have
Queen to e7 stopping that and now Queen
to f4 from f4 the Queen already guards
before so before once again becomes a
possibility well at least if the Queen
Bishop battery no longer controls the be
4 square so we have Knight to d7 and now
we we have b4 just attacking the bishop
with a captures a captures and now what
do you do here could you capture on
before you could capture on before but
then you face d6 and then you will have
to give up a piece since most your Queen
and Bishop will be
under attack so here Bishop the b6 is
played and now Magnus goes h6 pushes the
King further back we have King to g8 and
now d6
attacking the Queen here if he trade
captures captures you don't really you
don't really gain anything after we move
the Queen Knight to d5 is coming we're
gonna eliminate the bishop here then you
can use the the dark squares that even
for the harass the black King so not not
an option here
laconian played a queen to f8 and now
even east six and now we reach the
position from the thumbnail and it's
just it's just disgusting here look what
Liam really started to burn his time and
he has to play something so he played F
captures on e6 which is considered best
by the engine although not not that it
changes anything because here D captures
on c7 now just attacking the rook if you
if you move the rook then you no longer
have this knife protected on d7 but you
know yeah it's better just to give up
denied and to give up the roof so look
the c8 Magnus grabs the piece rook
captures on d7 we have rook to e7 now
the in defending against the rook on the
7 Frank and here Magnus just captures it
rook captures on e7 Queen captures on e7
and now as I haven't asked you to pause
the video in this game since there there
was there really was no reason to pause
it it was just like Magnus said after
after he gained control of the center
the game pretty much played itself which
you know kind of justifies the old
saying that he who controls the center
will win the game but feel free to pause
the video game here and try to find the
simplest way for whites to finish this
up while I give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations I know you're you're
probably thinking why should we pause
the video here we're up a piece I mean
do we really need to do this but well
yes because after Knight to d5 you are
up to two pieces so that that's even
better so this was called some plate and
it was in this position unmoved 32 in
that laQuan Liam resigned the game and
Magnus goes into day 3 of the world
rabbit championship being the sole
leader with eight points out of 10 games
now after the Queen moves there are no
good squares this is covered this is
covered
there you can move to faith but then
just Knight captures and v6 so you lose
another piece and of course you cannot
capture since the the pawn is pinned so
really incredible stuff I don't know Luc
Longley and probably thought okay Queens
gambit accepted to not played that often
in doctor play maybe maybe uh maybe he
prepared something for this tournament
and then he decided to test it out on
Magnus that's that's never a good idea
you know as we've shown here but you
know you don't know until you try I
don't think anyone else will try it in a
while
but yeah like I said so leader going
into day three with eight out of ten
points but tomorrow he will probably
have three 3 black three times black
pieces and only two times what a white
pieces since he had six whites and for
blacks for the first ten games so it's
gonna be interesting and the most likely
at tomorrow since the other two leaders
were Ivanko and Maxie Marshall de Graaff
who drew her game most likely Magnus
faces a mock scene for Sheila Gras I
don't know since not all the pairings
haven't been shown yet not all the games
have finished but we are going to show
at least one more game from day two I'm
gonna be checking up on your hashtag
suggestions and then we're gonna show
the standings before starting any games
from round through from from day three
so that's the game I do hope you enjoyed
it laQuan we definitely didn't I would
like to thank yo Schweitzer Julien your
Sade see BJ am vs Trevor Terrace and
ricardo de albuquerque for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - in my previous videos serum
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon
continuing with more games from the
world rapid and soon blitz championship
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your Friday